bienvenue par l autochtone ici c'est
melissa maulin dupuis cette semaine on a
reçu une question de betty qu'on va
écouter comment que les communautés
autochtones à autochtone pense y prendre
afin d'intégrer les médias et prendre
leur place justement là dans les médias
au québec
merci betty alors comment est-ce que les
premières nations peuvent prendre leur
place dans les médias du québec
c'est plutôt comment les médias du
québec peuvent-ils laisser de la place
aux autochtones et aux communautés
qu'ils sont enfants font partie aussi
d'une diversité de cultures et de nation
je pense que ça doit devenir d'une
volonté mais aussi je passe des fois il
faut que ça vienne du public
une volonté d organiser une volonté des
médiums et une volonté du public de
vouloir avancer chose de nouveau d'avoir
une voix qui est peut-être pas celle que
tu reconnais parce que on peut mettre
des premières nations
devant les caméras mais si les gens les
écoute pas c'est sûr qu'à un moment
donné ils vont se faire passer pour une
émission plus populaires pour un
animateur ou une animatrice qui ont
peut-être répondre plus des semblants
culturel ou à des visages plus connus
donc il faut être ouvert à des fois se
faire surprendre et même des fois se
faire surprendre par la langue parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que les
programmations souvent le français
l'anglais ce sont des langues secondes
donc quand on apprend une nouvelle
langue l'accent des l'accent de la
langue il nous l'accent de la banque
rivaud ressortir et ça peut être blocage
aussi pour avoir accès à des emplois
devant les caméras mais c'est de
s'intéresser aussi aux nouvelles qui
viennent des communautés parce que si
vous voulez avoir des premières nations
dans les médias c'est que vous voulez
entendre la voix des premières nations
et le message qui vient avec donc c'est
l'histoire et le vécu des communautés
alors même si je pense que déjà le fait
que te poses la question le fait que ça
t'intéresse c'est déjà une grande
ouverture pour que les communautés
viennent dans ton salon viennent dans
des journaux et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'on vous invite à nous envoyer des
questions 1 à partager les vidéos aussi
pour commencer à appliquer l'intérêt du
public québécois mêmes canadiens parce
que beaucoup de geeks sont francophones
en dehors des
des limites de la province du québec
donc merci encore betty propagation
était pas partager les vidéos n'hésitez
pas non plus à nous envoyer vos
questions à espace autochtone bonne
semaine